hey friends and welcome back to Deep
dive the podcast where it's my immense
privilege to every week sit down with
authors and creators and entrepreneurs
and other inspiring people and we find
out how they got to where they are and
the strategies and tools we can learn
from them to help live our best lives
now we are approaching the end of season
three of the podcast so thank you so
much if you have been a listener or a
viewer or a subscriber to the show
awesome to have you here and in this
episode we're going to do a little bit
of a Roundup of some of the top moments
from this season so if you haven't had a
chance to listen to all the episodes of
the Season then this will be great
because you'll get a lot of bang for
your buck or even if you have this will
be good space repetition of some of the
top moments some of the top lessons that
we've learned across the guests that
we've had in the last season of the
podcast so I hope you enjoy this little
Roundup episode your brain is capable of
anything I mean my new book is exactly
about that it's exactly about your brain
being able to uh to do anything what you
tell it to do right but if you leave it
uncontrolled its tendency its instinct
is to look for what's wrong why because
it's a it's a survival level machine
yeah it is there for the simple reason
of detecting if there is a tiger so it
can protect you okay and yes if there
are no Tigers it can go on and invent
iPhones but but you know if but it's
still even as it's inventing iPhones
trying to detect everything it's my boss
Annoying It's My you know boyfriend
girlfriend you know trying to leave me
or you know am I going to starve
whatever yeah right but that's until you
take charge if you take charge you know
that little voice in your head I
basically say it's like your computer
it's like your device you can tell it
what to do and it will do it and once
you start to take charge that machine
can be instructed to look for what's
right and when you look for what's right
my claim I have no scientific evidence
behind it that 99.9 of your life is
right okay whoever you are huh you know
I have you know I have a tiny bit of a
sore throat today but that happens to me
twice a year most of the year my my
voice is okay right most of us live live
our entire life on Solid Ground most of
us never ever see an earthquake right
ever unless it's in the news and even if
you do it's like once or twice in your
lifetime the Baseline of life is okay
yeah and then and then the negatives
just happen you know their dips out of
okay and then back to the Baseline right
and and when you see that then it's only
fair to instruct your brain if you want
to see the truth if you want to
acknowledge the truth of your life it's
only fair to instruct your brain to look
for 99
99.9 as I say of good things so I have I
have this very simple exercise when my
brain tells me something wrong about
anything okay okay I ask for nine other
good things about the situation my mom
occasionally asks me if I'm happy you
know and then I'm like yeah I feel like
life is a 10 out of 10 and she's like
but you don't look very happy I'm just
you know I have a resting bored face I
always seem to look too tired bags under
the eyes and all that stuff but the way
I was previously defining it was was
that kind of contentment was this sort
of Baseline level of peace and
acceptance and calm but then happiness
was a I I was always unsure is happiness
more like a kind of hour by hour minute
by minute fluctuation or or when we say
happiness are we referring more to this
sort of climate rather than whether this
idea of like long-term long-term-ish
contentment I'm happy with how life is
going the target is definitely to be
happy so so happiness is binary okay so
if you don't mind me talk about let me
talk about the happiness equation for a
minute when I when I struggled with my
unhappiness as a young man having been
given everything I was so fortunate I
had the most beautiful wife to amazing
kids you know fortune and power if you
want I had so much money the big Villa
and so on I was miserable right and and
the idea for me was like so what is
happening why why is that why is it not
working for me and I attempted in a very
crazy scientific way believe it or not
as an engineer I said okay so we're
gonna have to look for that happiness
thing and what do engineers do the first
thing they we do is we Define the
problem okay so what is that happiness
thing you need to know what it is before
you look for it and interestingly there
was no definition anywhere and so I went
out and I said okay let's write down
moments what we felt that thing called
happy I wrote down if I remember
correctly 92 bullet points at the time I
feel happy when my daughter smiles I
feel happy when I have a good cup of
coffee I have a I've been happy and I
have an enriching conversation and so on
and I started to look for a common
commonalities between those points in an
engineer's way I was literally looking
for a fitting line okay it's like you
know you take a few random readings from
a machine and you just put them on a
graph and if there is a line that line
is the equation of how that machine
performs I was looking for that line I
applauded those moments against
everything you know my height my weight
my you know age my hair on my head
whatever that is right I'm seriously I I
was very open to the idea of those
moments when I felt happy were they
because I lost my hair in my late 20s
that I started to feel unhappy so it's a
it's a worthwhile experiment but no
there was no relationship at all the
only relationship was this
happiness was not triggered by any
single event as a matter of fact the
same event I said I feel happy when my
daughter smiles that same event made me
happy most of my life it made me very
unhappy when she once failed a class in
school and came back to from from school
smiling right when you know why is that
when you know I'm generally I feel happy
on my daughter smiles but when she was
smiling after failing a class I sort of
had a feeling in my head that she may be
not that's not realize the weight of the
issue or that she's not responsible or
whatever but even the same event does
not always trigger happiness and when
you start to to see that you say so what
is happiness then it's not just the
events of our life there is something
else in the equation at play and the
other thing is your expectation
I expect that my daughter will smile all
the time other than the times where she
needs to be more responsible okay so my
expectation is when someone fails an
exam they should not be very happy okay
interesting now you put that in an
equation and suddenly it becomes very
clear happiness is events minus
expectations right if you want to
complicate the equation a little bit
it's equal to or greater than because if
events beat expectations so it's equal
to or greater than the perception of
events minus your your expectations of
how life should be okay so happiness
equation happiness is greater than or
equal to events minus expectations but
one I guess issue with this idea issue
inverted commas that I've never quite
been able to square is the response of
does that therefore mean that we should
just have low expectations for
everything in life and you know always
think of life with a slightly
pessimistic Outlook so that whatever
happens then life's it's a surprise and
it's a good thing
and when people say that to me I kind of
think yes yes asterisks well I don't
know what the asterisks if your Target
in life is to be happy yeah okay
honestly then yeah lower expectations
will make you happier okay so you know
if you basically tell yourself I know I
know many friends in my life that
decided that they've had enough of Life
uh you know the fast-paced lives they
went and lived in the Dominican Republic
and the only thing that would make them
unhappy on a day is that there is not
enough wind to kitesurf okay and they
make enough money to live a very simple
life and they want a kite surf that's it
their expectations are very low we don't
expect a Ferrari they don't expect to be
able to live in a big city they don't
want to go to museums they expect their
expectations are low and apply that to
anything I go to India and if you know
many many people hundreds of millions of
people don't expect to eat today give
them a bowl of rice and they're very
happy so if your target is happiness
yeah that's the way to go okay if your
target is success and impact on life
however you need to go to the art you go
you need to go the opposite way okay and
the opposite way is I need ambition so
you know when I wrote Saul for happy at
the beginning I wrote it with the
mission of 10 million happy yeah and
then 10 million happy happened very
quickly and my team got together and
said maybe we should set a bigger Target
so we didn't set 11 we didn't set 100
menu is that a billion happy now a
billion happy is a crazy Target to have
how many people in the world have
reached a billion people right but it's
a nice ambitious
a Target to Aspire to so when I wake up
in the morning year one when we've you
know we've achieved another 10 million
or so I don't tell myself that's it
we've achieved we're done yeah I say to
myself there is still way to go there is
still more to do okay but you're stuck
between those two extents if you want
one that says have no expectation at all
and you'll be happy yeah and the other
is it says have extremely high
expectations and you'll be successful
what's the problem with the modern world
is that we believed in this and not that
you know the problem with the modern
world is when you're growing up I I'm
sure I don't know your mom but your mom
told you success is more important than
happiness go thrive in life success
leads to happiness or that success leads
to happiness right so we believe that
yeah while it's not true I mean how
often do you meet someone who's
successful and Rich and Famous and
swimming and money and everyone's
attracted to them and paparazzis are all
around them and they're miserable okay
success doesn't always lead to happiness
now between those two there is a
midpoint like everything in life which
is I need a realistic expectation a
realistic expectation is not lowered
than how it should be yeah and it's not
higher than how it should be I need an
ambitious then the ambition that is
higher than the realistic expectation
and I need a contentment that sometimes
my even my realistic expectation might
be missed okay and in that case
while I aim for a realistic expectation
yeah and a high ambition I'm getting the
best of both words yes I'm trying to be
successful and at the same time I'm
contented as I go through that path when
life misses my expectations sometimes
the whole side has a thing so from when
I was 17 and I read the four hour quick
I was like all right cool side of this
is the way forward passive income blah
blah blah I spoke to a bunch of doctors
who I knew and I was like you know how
much you really enjoy your job if you
won the lottery would you would you
would you still do medicine and half of
them were like I would quit immediately
and the other half were like I'd go
part-time and I was like why don't you
go part-time and they were like well
because I need to pay the bills mortgage
kids Etc et cetera and so in my mind I
was like cool the clearly the answer
here is that like I want to be able to
do medicine for fun and I want to have
enough streams of passive income on the
side to be able to clothe myself feed
myself and buy a house and do all those
things because it seems like medicine in
the UK is not necessarily the path to
that right now yeah but then there's
some it's it is somewhat unfashionable
to suggest the whole side hustle thing
these days I guess when I was at
University you were like one of the OG
influencer side Hustler type people and
certainly in the book you kind of talk
about that a little bit
how do you think about this balance
between people could have side hustles
if they want to make streams of income
to become financially free et cetera et
cetera versus the kind of backlash to
that of like oh but now you're telling
people to work a second job in the
evenings and that's bad yeah so I think
that it's exactly that it's not black
and white and I think that when we
present it online as black and white and
actually if you're using any hours in
the evening to relax rather than using
those three hours to be building your
own Shopify page and making this much
money then you're you know you don't
like time you just like discipline like
all of these things I think that it can
both be true that you can make lots
through that and create a great life for
yourself through that and that also be
really kind of this kind of toxic tie
that I'd admit very much myself that I
kind of have in my own like head between
your productivity and your self-worth
and your ability to monetize every
single moment of your time I think that
I will be the first to say that side
hustles will be
are an incredible way to make money
outside of your main job or for me it
was when I was a student or even before
that I was babysitting every night or
doing music tutoring like all of these
things I kind of when I got into making
money it was actually because I became
obsessed with the fact that you know if
I get 20 pounds a month from my parents
I can make 25 pounds a month a night
from babysitting so I've already doubled
my technical income for the month and
just got completely obsessed with that
idea and then when I worked at IBM I was
doing the kind of Instagram stuff on the
side and selling stuff and that kind of
just snowballed and so I can't sit here
and say like oh no side loss is really
toxic
I think that it's marketed very
toxically and I think this we do need to
kind of question the idea that actually
the amount of money we can make is
capped only by our time and I also think
that we can acknowledge that actually
creating separate passive streams of
income is a really important and really
effective way to make more money and I
also think that now we're in an era
where that you know privilege is more
important to talk about than ever but
also at the same time the online space
has hugely democratized starting a
business in the way that the barriers to
entry to starting a business are way way
way lower yeah and so it's kind of I
just think that as long as we talk about
it with the Nuance of the whole
conversation then great I think when we
sell it as this kind of like you're
relaxing in the evening that's why you
don't have a house and that's why you're
not driving a Lamborghini I think that's
kind of I mean it just it sells on
Instagram doesn't it constantly so
excited by the concept of Tyler and I
can't wait to see you know how and where
it like goes and I think that thoughts
you know that fulfills me we have an
amazing team that are super excited all
the time and works so hard because they
believe in it too and I kind of hope
that shows I'd have to talk about some
book stuff working hard hardly working
uh there's a few a few things in here
which I found super interesting that I'd
love to get your take on and the the
first one was kind of very early on in a
way when I saw the title my editor
penguin actually sent me an advanced
copy of it I think I did a thing for it
or something and I kind of I saw the
title I thought it was going to be like
oh here is how you can work hard while
also being televised that kind of vibe
and then I I read the book I was oh okay
it's like this contrast but also not
this contrast between productivity and
self-care kind of so I would love to
hear your take on on that I know you
kind of literally written a whole book
about it but yeah what are your
current thoughts on productivity versus
self-care and that theoretical dividing
line between the two so I began to write
the book right at the beginning
because
it's kind of the stage where there were
these two big different kind of parties
online yeah one was like team
productivity and one was like team
self-care yeah and the protein
productivity one was like hustle 24
hours like sleep when you're dead like
all of these things are like big lions
in the background of like a big graphic
being like
yeah that kind of like sleep well you're
dead all of those types of things and
and it was just like hustle hustle
hustle like side hustle culture like
Forex Traders like you could make all of
this money but also like a more subtle
version of that which was like very like
girl boss culture like a lot of this
stuff which I will benefit is huge
hugely from and then there was this
other side which was like self-care and
that was like no like do what you need
to do cancel that job that you've got
for your well-being like quit your job
going to something you love like take a
bath put on a candle like well-being
and then it was like there was like
nothing in between so like if I post
something being like Oh one of my big
productivity tips is X I'd get like an
influx of like it's like pandemic like
productivity contest and like how dare
you say I should watch a TED Talk at
lunch like I should be out in the park
and it's like yeah great like if that
works for you at the same time I post
something being like I decided not to
work late today and to do this instead
and like the productivity people would
be like well like you can do that
because of X Y and Z and actually we all
need to do this and like all of that and
there was like there's no like middle
ground and actually there was this no
acknowledgment of the fact that actually
we all need productivity and we all need
self-care and that was the kind of like
working hard hardly working thing the
book split into working hard which is
filled with productivity tips a lot of
talk about the you know generational
kind of like passion paradoxes and like
all of these things managing your time
defining success goal setting like all
of these things a lot very much like
within this kind of like social media
world and then the the hardly working
side is is kind of essentially the
complete opposite but the whole idea is
to create a productivity blueprint that
doesn't completely negate the idea that
we actually need rest or relaxation or
sleep and I think that a lot of
productivity books and a lot of books
I've done really well in the kind of
like self-help but businessy worky
improve your life way are types of books
that you can like stick to for you get
really inspired by and stick to for
about two weeks after and then you're
like you completely burn out because
it's not sustainable because it's not
based on the fact that actually we're
all human as well and then on the
opposite side there's like all of these
well-being books that are like do this
and do this and do this and then after
two weeks you're like well now I've lost
my job so it's like there was there was
none of this middle ground and the whole
idea was to create a productivity
blueprint for this generation that
actually acknowledged the reality of
social media the 24-hour news cycle the
even things like house prices the fact
that we actually have to work for x
amount of time to be able to do X the
fact that we can do whatever online the
fact that we are bombarded with all
types of success whether it's like a
friend from school's marriage or
someone's promotion or you know like a
baby or like any of these things were
bombarded with those things all the time
so it's like very different from just
seeing who's the last to leave the
office all of these different things and
yeah the whole idea was to create this
this kind of blueprint and also take
what you need type thing that would be
really actionable but also was baked
into today's culture rather than being
like the stuff from back in the 2000s
that tells you to work x amount yeah I
know I love it makes money one of one of
the lines that I was listening to the
audiobook and you said sometimes
productivity can be self-care yeah and I
was like oh that's interesting what's
what's going on with that so I think
that's one of the like one of the main
triggers for the book was actually the
fact that like people would be like oh
self-care relax and I'd be like actually
sometimes self-care is meeting that
deadline that you're currently not on
track to me but actually respecting your
future self and your goals is getting
the [ __ ] up and doing the work that you
need to do for that and like we cannot
Market self-care as always like doing
nothing sometimes self-care is working
harder because you're currently not
working in line with what you want to
make happen and I think that again the
internet hates that because it's like
it doesn't fit into this idea of like
well-being versus productivity it's
the actual understanding of the fact
that both are one of the other like
self-care isn't always running about if
you're running a bath and you're about
to miss three deadlines and that's your
paycheck for the week self-care is not
running about I refuse to believe that
self-care is running a bath so that was
a lot of the stuff in the book is around
how to action actual self-care and like
how to know at what point something will
be self-care and versus self-sabotage or
any of these things to create a life
that revolves around you know your
boundaries and where you need to be more
productive and where you probably need
to stop being so harsh on yourself so
the book is titled building a second
brain a proven method to organize your
Digital Life and unlock your creative
potential a thing that we probably
should have addressed earlier but like
what the hell is a second brain and why
is it why does it help you organize your
Digital Life and unlock your creative
potential yeah yeah it's a great
question uh a second brain think of it
think of things you already do so you
might have a journal or a diary imagine
if everything you wrote in that journal
or diary was saved forever was
searchable that you could actually drive
insights from it you could go ask it a
question what have I thought about money
in the past what have I thought about
personal growth how have my dates been
in the past what did I learn you could
actually mine the insights from that
that's a journal or diary now imagine uh
notes you took from books or articles
now imagine even practical things like
grocery lists uh packing lists travel
itineraries okay now add bookmarks for
that you save from the web now add any
kind of document that you've created
from the past all these things are
things we largely already do to some
capacity but now imagine getting all of
that material which like we said is just
data all of that stuff is just
information and you you save it you
centralize it all in one single central
place where you know will be preserved
forever you know you can always search
for things you know you can once it's
say saved in the same place start to
link things together start to tag it
start to organize it what would be the
value what would be the you know what
would be the value of the the aggregated
sum of all that material that's your
second brain okay so a cynic would say
that well what is the value of that why
do I care if my like if it isn't it a
bad thing if my private Journal is in
one place for some evil Corporation to
access forever they're like why do I
need to care about my shopping lists
yeah books I've read I've read a few
fiction I've read Twilight I've read
Fifty Shades of Gray in addition to
getting things done why does it matter
if it's all in one place
yeah I would say a few things if you
make anything
and I'd say more of us are makers or
creators than you would think right if
you're writing long emails if you're
writing reports memos analyzes project
plans like most knowledge workers have
some virtually all knowledge workers
have some kind of output
you can't just sit down and make
something from scratch or if you do it
won't be very good you won't have a lot
of kind of interesting ideas to add to
it you need as a creative person some
repository some store of ideas and
insights to draw from or else you're
going to be doing that classic thing
that we want to avoid which is looking
at the blank page or looking at the
blank screen right and trying to come up
with an idea which is one of the worst
experiences I would say even broader
than making things think about decisions
a decision is something that you in a
sense create right you take into account
all this information all these inputs
what your team thinks what your
colleagues think how the economy is
doing what people in your industry say
you are incorporating all of those
inputs into a decision
I would say that is something that you
need to draw on existing material any
kind of outcome right like it's
difficult to to go out into the world
sort of naked in idea terms and make
things happen without any research
without any creative raw material
without any planning yeah it's it's just
hard to do okay yes so the way that I
kind of you know when people ask me oh
what's the deal with the second brain
thing I'm like it's basically a digital
note-taking system that you can put
anything into and that you can then use
for the things that you actually care
about yeah so I think this is very easy
to give an example to if you're for
example a writer you know there's this
idea of a commonplace book which is a
thing from from back in the day where
anytime you read a book or you have an
Insight you have an idea you write it
down in this one book and now if you
have multiple of these books that you've
collected through 10 years of your life
and you come to writing a book you're
like cool I now have all of these
insights I've already gathered I've
already got the raw materials it's
almost like taking notes in class yeah
you if if you're then writing an essay
you're mining the notes you've taken in
class doing a little bit of Googling but
mostly doing it from stuffy wrote a
class wider reading other insights maybe
a little note that sparked when you were
in a lecture and then you're assembling
your essay based on those raw materials
yeah rather than assembling your essay
from the Black Page yeah or attempting
to assemble your essay via a Google
search where you're just going to be
derailed by SEO content marketers who
are writing the most boring ass
listicles to help Drive content for
their things exactly so in a way you're
creating your own Google yeah you're on
sort of external brain your second brain
that you can then search for Relevant
things yeah and I guess that that's easy
enough to think about like let's say if
you're a student and you're writing
essays easy enough if you're like a
YouTuber you're like cool I get to mine
this for Content ideas
what about like not the not obvious
things like that or what other use cases
are there for a second brain outside the
scope of IMA content creator student
yeah you know there's all these little
mundane things just from people's
everyday lives like
I'll give one very simple example I'm
driving by the hardware store
as a parent
it's like I have to make use of every
single minute if I'm driving by the
hardware store I want to take advantage
of that opportunity opportunistically no
is there anything that I could just pop
in pull in right here pick it up from
the hardware store which is across town
right rather than trying to from my home
set aside all this time to go to the
hardware store so how so here's the
question how can I within seconds look
at some resource someplace and know all
the things that I might want to pick up
at the hardware store
and I did that to actually have this as
a case as a like a micro case study in
the book I I went into my notes went
into the project folder for the studio
that we were building went into one note
that had things to pick up at the
hardware store right which I could have
also done a search for and then right
there in the note I kind of reorganized
it put some things at the top put some
things in a section that says don't
worry about it for now and that way it's
like I can take advantage of a
spontaneous opportunity in my day which
is driving by this hardware store to
also pick up those items which I would
never be able to remember right and it
would also be hard to sit there in the
parking lot and try to like make a new
list and try to remember all the things
that we were talking about two weeks ago
that I have to pick up okay so it's like
your second brain is is offloading
functionality from your own brain to be
forced to remember things like three
weeks from now when I happened to be
swinging by the supermarket what are the
things that I need to grab yeah and so
it's not just like notes that you're
taking from lectures as it were or
videos that you watch or books that you
read it's also to-do lists for projects
that you're working on let's say you're
remodeling a studio let's say you're I
don't know getting something installed
in your kitchen let's say you're trying
to make your bedroom look a little bit
nicer yeah those are all I guess
projects yes in our life yes and unless
you're used to thinking like a
productivity nerd you might not think of
them as projects like yes you know
install bookshelf in bedroom or sort out
Cable Management on desk setup like yeah
I need for that well I need some cable
ties I need one of those like plastic
boxes to put into yeah I need some kind
of cleanings Implement for my keyboard
because my keyboard's a freaking mess
I'm not going to bother getting those
things right now so let's just Chuck
them in a to-do list such that next time
I happen to swing by the hardware store
I can just pick up those things and it
becomes a sort of seamless part of my
life is that kind of the idea exactly
yeah I think people sometimes they think
oh second brain this is this Advanced
futuristic technology it's going to be
this like you know exoskeleton that's
going to give me new powers and new
capabilities sure maybe eventually but
instead think about instead of the top
of your skill hierarchy the bottom what
is the stuff that you're trying to
memorize what is the stuff that you're
trying to keep in mind
right you know these little things are
you trying to keep in mind you know your
the homework assignments your kid has to
complete this week that you're helping
them with are you trying to keep in mind
um you know places you want to visit
next time you're in this country are you
trying to keep in mind the ideas from
the meeting with your boss last week are
you trying to keep in mind ideas that
have come up in a marketing meeting you
probably don't even realize it right
because we were never taught oh I think
you're trying to keep in mind don't keep
that in mind in fact we're usually
taught keep this in mind remember this
like you can even notice the things
people say in little these little
conversational moments they're like oh
can you can you remind me of this or
keep this in mind or bring this up next
time I'm always like no I can't I'm a
Fickle fragile human being I have to
write it down
so what happens if is if you replace the
instead of adding new levels of thinking
replace the bottom levels which then
frees up your time frees up your
attention frees up your energy which you
can then dedicate to those higher levels
just a quick break to tell you about the
sponsor of this episode and that is
surprise surprise short form short form
is the single best service that
summarizes the world's most popular
books it's great
um you've got loads of book like
literally hundreds to choose from
including this one digital minimalism by
Cal Newport which is very good but
actually I didn't read this book
initially I initially read the summary
of the book that was on short form and I
vibed with the summary and therefore I
decided to read the book but there have
been plenty of books where I've read the
summary and thought huh I've got the key
ideas maybe I'll read the book at some
point further down the line but right
now I don't have time and I benefit from
the ideas without necessarily needing to
read the book with apologies to whatever
authors but to be honest authors are
pretty chill about services like short
form because generally they encourage
more people to read the book and that's
generally how I use a book summary
service like this the other cool thing
about short form is that instead of just
summarizing the book's contents they
also do these little like interactive
segments that help you engage with the
ideas and you can actually be like oh
this is an exercise let me actually do
the exercise as I'm going through the
summary and if there's anything that the
author says that's particularly
controversial or objectionable then
short form we'll put a little note
saying that oh by the way that thing
that Cal Newport said in this book has
been completely disagreed with by that
thing that Tim Ferriss said in that book
and so you should read this one and it
just gives you more of an insight into
the world of ideas and how some ideas I
I think when it comes to non-fiction we
can often tend to take authors's ideas
at face value whereas short form really
helps us engage more critically with
those ideas which is awesome if any of
that sounds up your street and you want
to subscribe to the world's best service
that summarizes books then head over to
shortform.com forward slash deep dive
and if you hit that link which is also
in the video description and in the show
notes and that will give you 20 off the
annual premium subscription so thank you
so much short form for sponsoring this
episode what's your take on this idea of
kind of luck as a as a broad well yeah
so the luck stuff I was at Hearts
happened at hearts for 10 years I was
interviewing people for somebody else's
project actually I'd stepped in there
was my project interviewing people about
moments key moments in their lives and
this guy came in and just described
himself as really lucky he said I got
this chance occurrences they always work
out for me and bump into people
and increasingly convinced that we are
presented with opportunities all the
time and it's whether we make the most
of them I think it's really easy to
think this is my career path you know
I'm going to be a medic or I'm going to
be a magician or whatever it is
and once you lock into that the problem
is you then miss opportunities or other
ways of thinking and doing
and that happened at that moment you
know I was interviewing this guy and I
thought luck is really interesting topic
actually and psychologists have pretty
much ignored it
so I started to do some work on
psychology of luck and and we ran some
newspaper articles saying you know if
you think you're lucky or unlucky yeah
contact Richard Wiseman and then there's
about a thousand people get in contact
and it grew the media likely as a topic
and then that became the basis for the
the very first book and I never intended
to be an author at all I struggled to
read even so it just wasn't something
that I intended to do it just kind of
came along so you were I I guess were
you trying to publish academic papers in
Psychology journals yeah
absolutely I was doing that and I
published quite a lot of papers and then
through a guy called Simon Singh whose
amazing sort of mathematician and public
Communicator he introduced me to his
agent Patrick Walsh's incredible agent
and Patrick said what are you working on
and I actually at the time was working
mainly on the Paranormal so we put
together this book proposal about the
Paranormal
no publisher wanted to to Really put it
out it was a chance conversation with
Patrick he said what else she doing I
saw him doing stuff on luck and he said
we've tried to make people luckier I
said oh yeah we do that with
interventions and so on and that was the
the basis again of the very first book
okay so many questions about the
Paranormal stuff as well before we go
down that so I'll just put a bookmark on
there you've uh in is it the luck Factor
the lucky yeah so you've got like four
principles
um that people use to become luckier I
wonder if you can kind of elaborate on
those because I'm sure our listeners
would be right so these are the
principles the different ways in which
people lucky which lucky people think
and behave so we have the open to
Opportunities and when those
opportunities come along they make the
most of them and you saw that all the
time they're very flexible so they've
got an end point they knew they wanted
to I don't know be successful or you
know financially uh well off or whatever
it was but the way they're going to get
there they didn't really know they were
looking at the way the wind was blowing
and then setting sail to make the most
of that very flexible
um folks second they tend to trust their
intuition and it's when they get that
gut feeling they really do treat it as
an alarm Bell and take it quite
seriously
further optimists and so that becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy they kind of
continue in the face of failure and so
on and fourth I think it's probably the
most important principle uh they're
extremely resilient so when bad things
happen they could bounce back and so you
know I remember I interviewed to
hundreds of Lucky and unlucky people one
of them was this guy that was in the
lucky group and he came in for two
interviews between the two interviews
he'd fallen down the stairs and broken
his leg so the second interview comes in
with his leg and a cast yeah and I say I
bet you don't consider yourself quite so
lucky now and he says this wonderful
answer which still sticks with me he
said you're kidding he said you never
know the impact of something like this
he said sure it's annoying at the moment
but he said last time I went into
hospital I fell in love with a nurse
there we were happily married 25 years
later it was the best thing that ever
happened to me he said don't label it
bad luck you never know what's gonna
come from this yeah so it's incredibly
resilient yeah sort of attitude and so
those are the four things the the
opportunism uh the intuition the
optimism and the resilience and and is
that something that people can learn or
is it does it tend to be a sort of quite
innate trait and well that's a very good
question so obviously all of us uh are a
mixture of our genes and and and nature
and nurture basically and I'm not very
interested in the nature end of things
I'm not very interested in things that
can't change or don't change
so I think all of us can make the most
of our potential and that's the bit as a
social psychologist that fascinates me
the challenge is how do you do it how do
you do it and when I looked at these
self-help books I realized that this
stuff wasn't evidence-based people just
making things up some of it might be
helpful some of it might not be and so
we started to come up with interventions
and test them and that was the basis of
Life factor which which is these things
which actually we know make a difference
because we've done the the studies to
support it so going a little bit meta on
this like what does it look like to test
an intervention on something like luck
yeah if you're running the experiments
yes so I like experiments that pose
exactly those problems which is how do
you do that
um in our studies we would take groups
of people that didn't consider
themselves lucky or unlucky we'd ask
them to do something yeah and then you
monitor that group yeah your problem is
you haven't got a control group so there
is compared to what basically so you can
then have another group of people that
aren't doing doing anything problem
which is good better at least the
problem there is we you don't know that
maybe it's the doing of anything that
that kind of helps so we often have a
third Group which is that we say here's
a lucky mascot or a lucky charm carry
that a product exactly and that's the
sort of way you start to to look at
those interventions and so what what
kind of interventions are yeah we we did
Super Simple Things uh in part because
the complicated things didn't work so
for example uh we'd ask people to keep a
luck diary and now this was at the time
when positive psychology which Now sort
of falls under which was was around but
it wasn't huge we were doing some work
into this so the luck diary the end of
each day you write down a sense of
gratitude you have for your friends or
health or career or whatever gratitude
intervention or the best thing that's
happened in the last 24 hours or
something negative that used to happen
that no longer happens okay
and what that means you start to build
up a written record and you do have to
write it if you just think it doesn't
work you start to build up a written
record of how lucky you are how
fortunate you are how good your life is
and let's start to then change people's
self-perception
and that's when you start to see these
changes and behavior changes and
perception and ultimately changes in
physical health and well-being and
financial success and so on and and you
can measure all that well yeah I mean
that's what psychologists do some of
it's Ticky boxy stuff is how how good
you feel yeah and some of it is you know
a number of trips to your GP or
longevity of relationships or income as
much more hard measures okay what sort
of kind of numbers of people are we
talking in these kind of studies well I
mean this study is quite old now so at
the time we're probably running groups
of 50 something like that okay yeah so
yeah because I remember I did psychology
for my third year at Cambridge when we
do the interculated BSE thing and there
were all sorts of posters on the thing
would you like to be paid 20 pounds to
take part in a thing with a computer
game and a thing and no one quite knows
it's like I know this is a psychology
experiment so I know like you know
things are not quite as they seem yeah
but I had a bunch of friends who were
like oh 20 quid for doing a computer
game for an hour why not like this is
great money for a student it's yeah
they're fun I mean I I like experiments
that that are meaningful I mean a lot of
psychology experiments are the little
bit on the dull end I mean a
psychologists are astonishing they can
take something as wonderful as a human
being and reduce it to something really
dull really quite quickly so some of my
favorite luck studies was we would
invite people to be interviewed
but that meant they had had to go to a
certain room which meant they had to
walk along a certain Corridor and we'd
put money on the corridor yeah and so
the question is did they spot it and the
lucky people tended to spot it in The
Unlucky ones didn't as in luckier than
people who self-identify as like always
self-identified always a self-perception
okay yes
um and so by the time they got to the
room for the interview the study was
finished
there is no interview it was just
whether you spotted the five or ten
pound note yeah and so I love these
things we did so many of these these
great little studies ah there was one ah
I I gave it was some TV show I think
Darren Brown maybe had something to do
with it which was University bar where
you got sort of like red and blue coins
and like the red coins would give people
actual alcohol and the blue coins would
give people Placebo alcohol oh yes and
there was no difference in Behavior
between the two groups yes oh yeah I
don't know that Darren did that about
but yeah certainly I've done similar
stuff and then basically you realize
alcohol to a large extent is a placebo
which is uh phenomenal and Darren's
great Darren's fantastic he filmed his
first show ever uh I was part of that
first uh show and we met way back then
for 20 years that's something like
Durham Brown live I think this might
have been even mind games all the way
back okay
um so it's great yes yeah I saw him live
about two weeks ago and it's an
astonishing performance oh yeah he's
amazing I've seen all of his live shows
it's like yeah lucky journals so these
things work yeah they work they change
people's self-perception and one of the
things that that does is then change how
their friends and colleagues
um behave towards them okay so we forget
that we give off a certain you know self
identity Vibe yeah and that other people
reinforce that okay and so we come to
convince ourselves that's who we are
yeah and and once you start to change
that and other people see you as more
successful or lucky they'll give you
more opportunities or they'll talk to
you more or whatever it's in the same
way their emotions contagious you know
that we all like enjoy being around
happy people because it makes us feel
happy and and so the lucky people tended
to be happier they had a bigger social
network which meant they got more
opportunities but also when things went
wrong there were people there to help
them yeah the Unlucky people tended to
be social isolates what does your
process look like from I guess idea to
video being published what are the steps
along the way who are the people that
sort of get involved with making an idea
come to life yeah so let's go with uh
let's go with the classic video a
reviewing a phone yeah right so
Step One is the phone arrives at the
studio and I take it out the box
sometimes I'll shoot the unboxing if I
know that's going to be part of the
video and I put my SIM card in it I set
it up and I start using it and I start
testing it we have a so I actually
mentioned I forgot one of them earlier a
writer researcher script supervisor
David will help me with a lot of the
research and making sure we've got all
the points worth mentioning about this
device about this phone all in one dock
so I'm taking notes as I'm using it
we're brain dumping into this document
and then eventually we get to the point
where we're like all right I think we've
got it I think we've got everything
let's turn it into a script a story a
through line something that's worth
watching that's basically my job is to
to translate all of this information
into the headline the thumbnail the
thing that will live on YouTube
then we shoot the thing so there's sort
of two versions I'm sure you do this too
there's a-roll and b-roll so you shoot
your a-roll where you're talking to the
camera and then you have pieces where
you know you're going to be you know
you're talking but you also have like
footage ready for when you're gonna talk
about that stuff we typically start with
shooting a-roll so that I have all of
the talking out of the way and then we
know all the little quirks and things
that I've mentioned and then we will go
shoot all of the rest of the b-roll to
cover all the things we need a lot of
that is Vin and Brandon shooting b-roll
off on their own a lot of that is I've
got a couple shots in mind I need I'll
I'll grab them and go up to the roof and
we'll go shoot some stuff that I know we
need to get we cover the whole script
everyone has access to the script then
it gets edited for the most part that's
just me ingesting all the footage and
laying it down on the timeline and then
if there is any sort of extra fancy
visuals then we'll go sort of Next Level
say this one as a robot shot in the
intro I'll be editing the main video
while Andrew Vin and Brandon will go off
to the robot studio and will make their
incredible Masterpiece and then that can
tie in back to what I've been editing so
they'll give me a couple ideas we'll
pick one we'll go this is one that would
really work with the YouTube tagline and
sort of you can see the Whirlwind
happening as the content gets made it
gets to the end of the process I finish
the video we give it one last walk
through the whole timeline watch the
whole video together any last
adjustments okay it's good export upload
publish I go glimpses of your view into
this in your culin and some Air
interview but how how are you thinking
about short form content like shorts and
reels and tick tocks and I know you've
got the MKBHD shorts Channel where some
of the stuff on that has been cool but
for example if you again if you wanted
to you could 10x your output on short
short form content to think and you
could be thinking hey Tick Tock is where
all the kids are at let's just bang out
the content on Tick Tock but it seems
like you're not going down that approach
so yeah how do you how do you think
about tick tocky type content yeah okay
so that last point you made is really
very close to how I think about it is
like the uh the demographics of our
audience so again I'm 28 a lot of my
audience is right from about
14 to 35 let's say just like 15 years
less to maybe 15 years older just
somewhere on there and endlessly
probably undefeated with creators what
I'll see is as they get older their
younger audience that was closer to
their previous age becomes less
interested and I guess their older
audience becomes more interested so when
I see Tick Tock I'm like that's where
the youngest parts of my audience will
inevitably be if I want to talk to those
people and anyone using tipac that
doesn't mean you're a child that just
means like that's the average of what a
tick tock scroller is doing if I want to
reach that younger audience I guess I
should be on Tick Tock but is that my
goal or am I really just concerned with
reaching the same people who are making
a purchase decision who who have some
disposable income who have a choice to
make about what piece of tech to buy and
maybe the age of those people isn't
going to change I mean it's cool to get
kids into Tech I still think that's
awesome and I think there is probably a
cool way that we can make short form
content that is interesting to younger
audiences and maybe that's a net
positive because we can get people
interested in Tech and that's cool but I
think the Target demographic is actually
the same age as it's always been whether
it's shorts or longer videos or podcasts
or anything like that so it sounds like
you don't feel that pressure of like
like I've spoken to a bunch of other
creators who and myself included who
sort of feel that pressure of oh crap
Tick Tock is where where all the new
people are everyone shows that like
maybe YouTube is on the decline am I
gonna stay relevant by am I going to try
and force myself to stay relevant by
kind of adapting and becoming a tick
tocker as well yeah okay so that's a
different question so relevant if my
goal was just to be famous which I don't
want then I would be all in on Tick Tock
right but here's a different way of
thinking about it when I'm going to
search for the new iPhone comes out
where do I go look for that video I go
to YouTube dot com and I type in the
YouTube search box that is where I want
to live for those people who are
searching for that information if that
answer ever changes if it's like the new
phone came out let me go into Tick Tock
and see what people are saying about the
phone then I guess that is when I'll
feel that pressure but I think for the
people who feel the pressure to be
relevant or the pressure for the
eyeballs or the fame or something like
that then you'll feel the pressure
because Tick Tock is a hundred percent
accomplishing that now the most viewed
piece of content I have ever made in 15
years is a 12 second Tick Tock of me
unfolding the LG wing it has 35 million
views if I wanted the eyeballs I would
be all over Tick Tock but I think it's
different it's just that people
searching for things the people making
purchase decisions I'm trying to make
valuable content for them and so that's
still YouTube have you ever have you
found any other sort of metal skills
that are generally useful for Life yes
but they weren't taught in University so
one is storytelling and selling I think
the number one skill that helped me be a
straw founder especially in the early
days of building our business is the
ability to sell and I think I'm blessed
in the sense that that's just one of my
intuitive superpowers it's something my
dad worked on with me as I was growing
up he he was really focused on my
ability to articulate uh he thought that
was really important I ended up taking a
business communications class at
Michigan but to be totally honest I
didn't find it very valuable half the
time was spent doing kind of public
speaking half the time was spent
literally like digital communication
like how to write an email and I found
that to be tough tough as in like not
helpful but yeah I mean sales I would
say is that if you are trying to elevate
yourself as a professional in any way
not just as an entrepreneur just in your
career you find yourself selling
yourself far more times than you realize
so like just even talking about a
business when we were starting boarding
Brew we're talking about a startup that
was a media company media companies are
generally not Venture backable so you
can't raise from institutions we had a
newsletter that's all we had we had 30
000 subscribers at the time we weren't
making any money but we had to raise
money in order to possibly get to a
place of making money and so selling
investors on why a 21 year old and a 19
year old who have a media company where
media companies are generally not
profitable businesses and we weren't
making money yet and by the way it's not
really a media company it's a newsletter
we had to sell them on why they should
put their hard-earned money in our
business we had to sell our initial
employees on why they should leave their
steady jobs to join a business that's
making zero dollars and we had to sell
advertisers because that was the first
way we made money as a business we had
to sell advertisers like Discover Card
large financial institutions on why they
should even bother wasting their time on
a company that reaches thirty thousand
people versus allocating that type to
thinking about say a television
commercial that reads mail reaches
millions of people
and so I'd say that is the number one
meta skill I'd actually argue it's a
metascale even like in personal life not
just professional life I've I've heard a
lot of people say that that you know the
the skill of selling is kind of yeah is
well one of the one of the most useful
skills you can have but I've always kind
of wondered and I never quite followed
this thought of like what does what does
that actually mean like I wouldn't say
I'm good at selling but I've I guess I
have sold stuff in the past and I just
don't really think of
selling is like a thing you sell
yourself on YouTube every time you post
a video like and this is actually an
interesting thing of and I've thought a
lot about this is what's the difference
between sales uh or selling and
storytelling
and my view is just if something comes
off as selling it's just shitty
storytelling and so my view is like why
do people watch your videos for a long
time why did you just hit 3 million
subscribers on YouTube when there's a
bunch of an abundance of content because
you're not the first person to talk
about topics related to productivity to
bettering yourself right you have found
a way to storytell in a way that
captivates people and keeps them engaged
so you are innately good at storytelling
I just don't think I think it is quite
natural and intuitive to you it doesn't
feel like work to script and then uh
deliver that in front of a camera you
couldn't be where you are today without
being exceptional storytelling how do
people get better at this it's a great
question
um my answer would be it's a combination
of practice
of shadowing and feedback and of
understanding the fundamentals of what
it means to storytell well
so going in reverse order
I think that they're they're tried and
true there's the science to it there's
like tried and true formulas for what is
a captivating story for people uh and so
like for example I'm reading uh the book
creativity Inc right now which is the
story of Pixar like there are there are
story arcs which is like there is a hero
the hero is on a journey the hero on the
journey experience is a challenge in
experiencing the challenge they go
through adversity they overcome the
challenge and they reach their goal like
that is one story arc I think there are
a number of formulas this way so at base
level I think studying the best
storytellers of all time uh and studying
the formulas that they use to tell
stories is the first step the second
step is what I would say is the
combination of practice and shadowing
and so the example I'll use for you is
in the early days of morning Brew when
we had to pitch advertisers on
advertising in our newsletter I had
never sold in a professional setting
anything before but I had to do it there
was no option we had to make money and
so I you know got reps pitching probably
in our first year 250 advertisers on 30
minute calls about who morning Brew was
what we stood for and why spending your
money with us was worth your time and
your money based on what your goals were
and the first pitch I did probably
second Pitch probably the 20th pitch I
did was really bad but every time I
would take five to ten minutes after a
pitch and I'd have a reflection period
where I would write down what are the
things that I think I did well and what
is one thing I would change for the next
pitch I do and I would record every
pitch I did as well so then thinking
about shadowing and feedback right I was
delivering feedback for myself but a big
thing that I did with our junior sales
people when they joined morning Brew was
when they would do a pitch in the early
days I would join them on those call
calls so that first of all like I would
do the sales pitch they would listen to
me so they would sponge up that
information we would do that for a few
weeks and then gradually I would hand
off the reins to them where they would
start doing the pitch we would record it
we would listen back to it together
after which by the way for anyone who
hasn't listened to their voice before
and hasn't listened to themselves to a
sales pitch it is going to be
excruciating for you to do the first
time but it is so valuable I would give
them feedback and then they would use
that feedback the next time and you know
you look at a company like uh Gog gong
is a multi-billion dollar sales software
company there's a reason it's such a
valuable business so what Gog basically
allows you to do is allow sales orgs to
record every sales call they have and
then in in a database holds all of the
sales calls organized by who the seller
was the type of client that it was and
it also will do things as sophisticated
as say what percentage of the time on
the call were you talking versus what
percentage of the time was the person
talking and it will categorize what were
you talking about almost like you know
on YouTube how you can kind of set the
the chapters of an episode it does that
automatically in your sales call and so
then any seller can go on to gong and
study what are quote unquote the best
calls that have led to the conversations
that convert their clients at the end of
the day there is the there is this Art
and Science to understanding what works
for you to storytell the way that
leverages your strengths but also
understanding the science of what works
well and what are kind of like the the
the natural story arcs that people over
the course of time are always attracted
to nice that's a that's a great answer
was that off the cuff or have you have
you thought about that that was off the
cuff
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye